[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález tal vez el
mandatario más incrédulo de todo el
mundo en torno al coronavirus donald
trump ha sido diagnosticado con kobe 19
un virus que negó critico subestimó y
ahora padece después de dos días de
hospitalización y detener al mundo
entero al tanto de su condición el
mandatario regresó a la casa blanca y no
ha tenido actividades en su agenda en
las últimas 24 horas esta enfermedad y
un largo tratamiento contra el cob y de
19 llega cuando quedan pocas pocos meses
ya o pocas semanas para las elecciones
presidenciales
trump no lideran las encuestas y hay
mucha especulación en torno a su
enfermedad
el presidente de trompe y varios de los
integrantes de su equipo de trabajo de
la casa blanca también se han visto
contagiados con el móvil 19 veamos de
quién se trata
esta fotografía muestra la cantidad de
personas cercanas al presidente trump
que sin saberlo pueden estar contagiadas
con kobe 19 y 9 de ellos ya dieron
positivo por el virus la más reciente en
confirmarse fue la secretaria de prensa
del mandatario ok la imagen en uno de
los personajes más reacios a usar
mascarilla después de dar negativo de
manera constante e incluso todos los
días desde el jueves dispositivo para
covite y 19 este lunes por la mañana sin
experimentar síntomas definitivamente no
tenía conocimiento del diagnóstico de
job y hicks antes de la conferencia de
prensa en la casa blanca del jueves
makinen y fue una de las asistentes a la
ceremonia de nominación de amy cón y
barber como puesta a la corte suprema en
el evento del que participaron más de
200 personas y donde sólo unos pocos
usaron mascarilla
también estuvieron la propia barberá el
vice presidente mike pence y el fiscal
general william bar todos ellos han dado
negativo sin embargo habrá que esperar
los 14 días del periodo de incubación
del virus para determinar el número de
contagiados los ojos también están
puestos sobre el primer debate
presidencial entre joe biden y dona
donde los acompañantes del presidente se
quitaron las mascarillas según una
investigación de washington coast que
consultó a la comisión de debates
presidenciales esto constituyó una
violación de las reglas que acordaron
ambas campañas aunque los hijos del
presidente y sus parejas también han
dado negativo este puede haber sido otro
de los focos de contagio en la casa
blanca
el más reciente integrante de la casa
blanca en ser diagnosticado con kobe 19
es stephen miller uno de los consejeros
del presidente hace pocos minutos fue
anunciado ayer de washington que ha dado
positivo en una prueba que le fue
practicada y se convierte en el último
en esta larga lista de personalidades
cercanas al mandatario estadounidense
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
maría tereza allá ella es analista
internacional también es coordinadora de
la maestría de asuntos internacionales
de la universidad externado de colombia
se encuentra en la ciudad de bogotá
también está con nosotros
xavier domínguez él es consultor
político
de guys and wind y está en la ciudad de
miami en el estado de florida y
finalmente se une también a esta
conversación víctor lópez torrents él es
estratega y consultor político
internacional nos acompaña desde la
ciudad de san salvador en el salvador
ustedes también pueden ser parte de este
debate dejen sus comentarios en las
redes sociales nos encuentran como
france24
sant y luego la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f 24 eje todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas tenemos el tema tenemos a
los invitados y el contexto entonces
comenzamos y quiero preguntarle a maría
tereza cómo afecta este diagnóstico del
presidente donald trump a su campaña y a
esta carrera presidencial maría tereza
buenas noches santiago un gusto estar
aquí con ustedes es una pregunta
interesante porque el presidente no
venía bien en la carrera electoral su
campaña está poco menos echando agua y
es un presidente que a lo largo de este
año de este 2020 se ha mostrado como no
creyente del coi 19 bastante se ha
burlado bastante del cover y de pronto
le da al cover y uno pensaría que va a
aprovechar el momento que su campaña
está bastante regular para salir y decir
miren esto es algo duro
tratar de ser empático con la gente un
país que tiene más de 210 mil muertes
por temas del cob y tratar de generar
una empatía y decir esto se puede
combatir pero lo vamos a hacer juntos la
salud que yo tengo el acceso a la salud
que yo tuve en estos días en el hospital
tiene que hacerse extensivo a todos
estos no generó empatía
yo creo que perdió una oportunidad
interesante para ganar algunos adeptos
es más dentro de las propias filas de
los republicanos si hay gente incrédula
no puede creer que haya hecho esto de
esa manera el presidente de trump que
haya desaprovechado la oportunidad hay
gente me comentaba en el otro día por
ejemplo cuando salí a darle la vuelta al
hospital en su carro que decía no eso no
puede ser el presidente el presidente
está enfermo él no va a ser no va a
poner a su gente no la va a exponer eso
tiene que ser un doble como los que usan
en las películas para agradecerle a los
demás mientras él se cuida en el
hospital yo creo que el presidente
perdió una gran oportunidad que tenía de
enfrentar a la gente se le miren esto
puede ser peligroso pero de manera
combatirlo y tratar de generar empatía
estoy con todos los que han perdido
gente mis simpatías a ustedes porque yo
ya he vivido primera mano lo doloroso
que puede ser esto y en vez de eso salió
a decir frases como será que soy primero
pero yo soy como muy poderoso soy un
héroe soy terrible javier para continuar
con esta ronda con esta primera pregunta
que tanto afecta entonces esto la
campaña del presidente trompo
pues yo creo que no sólo afecta a la
campaña del presidente trump yo lo que
creo es que afecta a la campaña de los
eeuu y hay que ver analizar esto no
desde el punto de vista de la salud
esto es una campaña electoral en la que
todo vale y lamentablemente se utiliza
todo cómo se utilicen tantas y tantas
ocasiones de que estamos hablando aquí
de que una elección la gana el que
domina la conversación y las encuestas
no le benefician al trump y volvemos a
tener un debate de si trump tuvo como
visto otro auto vucovich que si dice la
verdad o no dice la verdad de si trump
llegar al debate o no llegará al debate
de si miente o dice honor miente es
decir vuelve a hacer sin ánimo de
defender la actitud que yo creo que
desde el punto de vista de la ética no
es responsable lo que está haciendo pero
sí de lo que estamos analizando es de
estrategia electoral tiene esa capacidad
de volver a convertirse en el eje de la
conversación y de la comunicación en
cualquier momento y eso no lo logra un
candidato como bailén por lo tanto yo
creo que desde el punto de vista
electoral desde el punto de vista
electoral tiene grandes oportunidades
para mejorar su expectativa electoral no
olvidemos
no olvidemos que en la última elección
la ganadora de las encuestas de hillary
clinton y el ganador del fue donald
trump y volvemos a estar en una
situación bastante similar es cierto que
en este momento el presidente tiene una
afectación de credibilidad muy alta
motivos no faltan ha mentido en
innumerables ocasiones pero le permite y
yo creo que es lo que vamos a ver en los
próximos días el relato precisamente de
héroe de se enferma no le pasa nada si
existe el virus pero no era un tema
importante a pesar de que mucha gente
este ha sufrido este vuelve a hablar
bien de los doctores de su capacidad de
reacción es decir y sobre todo lo que yo
creo que es estamos a pocas horas de que
suceda de su comparativa con reagan que
es con quien siempre ha tenido digamos
esa voluntad de parecerse y no hay que
olvidarse que reagan una vez fue
tiroteado y regresó digamos a la
presencia a los pocos días cuando fue
intervenido por cáncer de colon regresó
también a los pocos días y es un tema
que en el electorado americano funciona
esa reacción del héroe que regresa otra
vez a la oficina trabaja
y que confía en el sistema de salud
americano etcétera etcétera etcétera le
da un relato para volver a capitalizar
la elección entonces de qué estamos
hablando de que si lo que hace es ético
no de lo que hace
funciona en campaña si de que se domina
la conversación totalmente víctor su
opinión que tanto tiene entonces esto de
estrategia ya nos han dado algunas luces
de como esto ha modificado y está
afectando la campaña del presidente
trump el proceso electoral en general
entonces como lo califica usted como una
estrategia vi la estrategia de campaña
sí sí definitivamente es una estrategia
móvil pero si es una estrategia de
campaña efectivamente toman las riendas
otra vez de la elección
hamas donald trump había sido tan viral
perdóneme la analogía
y por ejemplo quitarse la mascarilla
como vimos ayer es un gesto que podría
valer una elección de acuerdo al
presidente de una tanda positivo está en
un grupo de alto riesgo al tener 74 años
pero yo creo que toda esta situación le
ha jugado a su favor primero no tiene no
tiene la necesidad de ir a más debates y
se procede a una fase de victimización
de empatía con esos doctores con la
gente que ha pasado que ha pasado por el
virus de alguna manera de forma parte de
todos esos 7.5 millones de contagiados
que lo crean pero que eran
y se produce un mejor escenario para la
narrativa como presidente que derrotó al
hobbit se le ve mucho más fuerte el
mismo afecta ha afirmado que se siente
mejor ahora que hace 20 años
y de alguna manera al estar enfermo sea
en estos últimos estas últimas semanas
de la elección la campaña de baile a
pensárselo dos veces antes de atacar
directamente de ahí vamos a ver a una
campaña mucho más emocional yo estoy
completamente de acuerdo con xavi o sea
vamos a un tram que apela al patriotismo
a ese sentimiento patriótico fundacional
estadounidense ese vídeo el vídeo de
ayer que te regresa triunfal que tocó
dentro de la psique de muchos americanos
un presidente enfermo que está
cumpliendo con el deber yo he visto a
muchos analistas que critican dicen que
tranvía perdido porque no va a poder
hacer territorio eso no es cierto eso no
es cierto las elecciones estadounidenses
va mucho más allá del puerta a puerta
y yo vaya yo creo que estará
invisibilizado las dos próximas semanas
porque como hemos visto de repente todos
los focos se han puesto en entrar y su
estado de salud y ha habido un ligero
repunte en las encuestas víctor sigo con
ustedes saliendo nos un poco del tema de
trump y pasando más al tema de campañas
va a ser ahora la ronda a la inversa
cierro con maria thereza
este tipo de noticias este tipo de
estrategias que ustedes han señalado que
están utilizando la campaña que puede
ser una estrategia es algo de lo que
estamos especulando por hay muchos
argumentos para creerlo
puede darnos a entender que tal vez está
cambiando la forma de hacer campañas
políticas estas campañas pasarán un poco
más a la virtualidad teniendo en cuenta
que ya no van a poder hacer los mítines
como es habitual los rallys en las
diferentes ciudades en los diferentes
estados ya yo vaivén dijo que tal vez no
era necesario hacer los otros dos
debates si el presidente de trump seguía
estando con una condición médica pues
compleja
entonces modificaría la forma de hacer
campañas políticas en el siglo 21
sí definitivamente modifica la forma de
la pandemia ha arrasado muchos en muchos
aspectos sea por ejemplo hemos visto
como 75 ó 75 elecciones ya se han
pospuesto
inevitablemente está tocando
directamente hacia cómo se están
realizando las elecciones para mí un
ejemplo fue las elecciones de corea del
sur por ejemplo todo con discursos
virtuales no hubieron practicamente
manifestaciones en las calles en eventos
en las calles etcétera pero luego
también hemos tenido las últimas
elecciones de república dominicana en la
que nosotros participamos y ahí sí vemos
caravanas vimos muchas movilizaciones
vimos poco distanciamiento social
etcétera y eso es lo que está ocurriendo
se al final estamos yendo hacia eso no
nos están respetando seguimos viendo
manifestaciones en las calles de todo
tipo con posibilidad de contagio
volviendo a la elección estadounidense y
entrando lo que hablábamos antes
efectivamente que estamos viendo ahora
mismo una situación con cifras muy
parecidas a las de 2016 donde la gran
mayoría de encuestadores comentaristas y
medios de comunicación del mundo daba la
victoria a hillary y ya sabemos quién
ganó finalmente con lo cual hay que
tener una cosa en cuenta que contra nada
está escrito y tram puede volver a la
jugada en cualquier momento así que no
es conveniente decir que tranvía perdido
porque no es cierto para
sí y aparte tenemos el problema tal
breakers es sólo han habido si no
recuerdo mal llegado ford en 1966 jimmy
carter en 1980 y george bush padre en
1992 que fueron derrotados en las
elecciones nacionales como presidentes
de 1933 con lo cual podemos ver que no
hay nada escrito las elecciones también
se es y este giro quedado trump
definitivamente le ponen el foco de
elección si algo nos ha enseñado estos
cuatro años de gobierno throne creo que
a ustedes analistas especialistas en
campañas políticas sean nosotros los
periodistas es que el gobierno de trump
es impredecible y todo puede pasar desde
su llegada a la casa blanca todo fue
completamente una sorpresa para el mundo
entero
xavier su opinión al respecto sobre este
cambio este giro que dan entonces ahora
las las campañas políticas con esto que
nos están dejando ver en eeuu resulta
muy interesante un poco más virtuales en
los candidatos jugándose cartas como
está el presidente de trump donde se
pone la salud del mismo mandatario en
juego
sobre la mesa del debate para ganar
votos y para convencer al electorado
bueno yo creo que con el debido
y respeto y con absoluto cariño a lo que
voy a decir ahora yo creo que no podemos
analizar los procesos electorales desde
el punto de vista de los latinos o el
polo el proceso electoral norteamericano
o estadounidense desde el punto de vista
de los latinos porque primero porque en
las campañas en latinoamérica
fundamentalmente se carga el peso de la
responsabilidad del resultado electoral
en un factor de movilización y en el
caso de las elecciones americanas y
también en el caso de las elecciones
europeas en su mayoría los procesos de
responsabilidad respecto al resultado
están en los factores de comunicación y
no de movilización esas eternas
discusiones de que hay que llevar a la
gente a la urna de que la llevan a la
fuerza o de que los moviliza no se les
paga el transporte está bien para méxico
para colombia para ecuador perú no
porque el voto es obligatorio eso es
porque comunicar la merecida victoria de
américa latina tiene una manera de hacer
campaña entonces no podemos decir
como ha afectado las campañas del cómic
si en algún sitio ha afectado menos el
comité en el proceso electoral es el
tema de eeuu porque todo estaba en
internet de todo está en la televisión
porque todo está en los medios masivos y
por qué no aquí no vienen a buscarte yo
que con eeuu y no viene nadie a buscarte
para que vayas a la urna ni te ofrecen
dinero ni me traen a despensa de comida
ni nada de esto no tiene nada que ver
todo el mundo seguimos el proceso
electoral igual que lo seguíamos hace
cuatro años quizá ahora desde casa y
antes de lo comentábamos en los
restaurantes y ahora no porque pues por
tema de la pandemia estamos en esa
situación y luego la utilización de este
tipo de cosas es histórico o sea no es
solo donald trump cuantos no son los
presidentes que se han inventado de
temas de difamación es que no existen
ataques que no existe acuérdense de la
presunta bomba de eta que al final nunca
se supo que se puso en el coche del
presidente aznar y que salió caminando
pone una bomba en el coche el coche no
vuelca el coche no rompe y se se crea un
eros en todo esto es un recurso hombre
éste insisto otra vez desde el punto
vista profesional con respeto con cariño
que desde la ética no es recomendable
desde el punto de vista de la estrategia
es arriesgado y hay que analizar las
circunstancias y este hombre que
teóricamente va abajo en las encuestas
en voto popular no en votos de estados
en voto popular es lo mismo que hillary
hace este en cuatro años pues está
utilizando todas las herramientas que
tiene y si tiene el tema del cómic para
ahora tener diez días para explicar
incluso que encontró la vacuna o que se
reduce la curva o que infinidad de cosas
que yo creo que vamos a ver en donald
trump de aquí a la elección porque es un
personaje sin duda alguna que no sabemos
por dónde nos va a salir impredecible
interesante ese punto que aclaró usted
sabía era allí en la ciudad de miami
maría tereza a sus impresiones sobre
estos estos últimos días del acontecer
en eeuu esta especie de incertidumbre
que generó un poco
en los ciudadanos en el mundo entero
esta hospitalización del presidente
trompo
cierto fue una gran incertidumbre y yo
acá quiero decir que me uno a mis
colegas en decir que estos son unas
elecciones atípicas pero yo creo que son
las elecciones que nos van a tocar y les
va a tocar a la nueva generación las
manifestaciones en la plaza pública no
sólo en américa latina' tarde o temprano
en los otros países también están ya
manda vas a recoger hoy en día la gente
joven sobre todo se informa sobre
quiénes son los candidatos y les es que
acaso le interesa cuáles son sus
plataformas en las redes sociales
entonces estamos asistiendo a un cambio
en la manera de hacer política donde no
obstante se mantienen ideas tales como
premisas básicas de los políticos a mí
no me importa que hablen bien de mí a mí
no importa que hablen mal de mí
catastrófico sería que no hablarán de mí
siendo yo político y eso lo maneja muy
bien trompo
sin embargo trump a pesar de todo esto a
pesar de que está el voto el colegio
electoral a pesar de que el voto popular
no es realmente el que más le interesa
en este momento según pareciera es un
personaje que no genera empatía a
diferencia del rey gan
decían ahora cuando salió del hospital
luego de que fue herido no genera
empatía por el contrario parece que es
bastante errático un día dice voy a
demandar las elecciones si no pierdo
pero hace cosas que uno dice está
tratando de perder casi esta falta
empatía yo insisto es una de ellas una
cosa es ser fuerte frente al virus
utilizarlo todas las armas son válidas
en la política eso es cierto pero si yo
recuerdo la historia y pongo el ejemplo
de winston churchill que dijo yo voy a
combatir en todos los frentes a mi
enemigo y los voy a combatir no importa
lo que pase una cosa es decirlo otra
cosa ser irracional y pararse debajo la
bomba que están tirando los alemanes y
eso parece ser lo que está haciendo el
presidente trump
maría teresa eso en cuanto al presidente
de tron que ya lo vimos a lo largo de
este fin de semana incluso estando
hospitalizado seguía mandando mensajes a
través de las redes sociales incluso
vídeos a sus seguidores y por supuesto
los medios de comunicación allí
estábamos esperando que para saber qué
era lo que yo voy a decir hablemos del
candidato demócrata joe biden ha
aprovechado esta coyuntura como ha
jugado a favor esto o en contra este
tipo de situaciones que se están
presentando en el panorama
yo creo que aunque no haya hecho grandes
manifestaciones rescató por ejemplo su
primer trino luego de que se supiera que
trump fue positivo y es estamos rezando
por el presidente de trump y por su
familia está generando valga la
redundancia la palabra en empatía se ha
aportado respetuoso con el pueblo
americano sobre todo respetuoso por
ejemplo las pérdidas de vida que ha
generado el kobe 19 en eeuu
ha tenido estrategias para combatir esto
ha dicho que cuando llegue a la
presidencia por ejemplo va a haber una
reforma en salud porque todos hemos
visto la cantidad de remedios que le han
dado al presidente de trump y es
maravilloso el presidente de un país
como eeuu tiene que tener este equipo
médico detrás pero lo deja uno con un
mal sabor pensando en la cantidad de que
no tiene acceso a lo más básico no a los
grandes remedios del presidente trump
pero lo más básico y eso es algo que
bardem ha aclarado en estos días y ha
dicho bardem es una persona de 78 años y
tal vez las redes sociales a decirle que
dan un poquito grande y pensaría uno
pero sus asesores tienen que aprender a
hacer un uso mayor de esto yo sé creo
que la imagen para muchos electores en
las redes sociales es la manera como
ellos van a escoger un candidato es lo
único que conocen muchos de ellos no
leen el periódico y menos ven las
noticias
xavier sus impresiones en torno a la
candidatura de by the end en esta
coyuntura
bueno yo varias varias consideraciones
la primera de ellas es que va a ir en
encabeza las encuestas porque trono
acierta no es por los aciertos de yo
vaivén que sería un surfero en este
proceso electoral del montadito en la
tabla este de vez en cuando obama habla
de él y le aplaude y no es que digas hay
una campaña y vuelvo a lo mismo en no
estoy hablando de ideologías hablando el
punto de vista profesional de la campaña
de joe biden sería un plato de sopa sin
sal no tiene nada y la de donald trump
seguramente lleva un exceso de picante
digamos la sopa y por lo tanto de eso
generar malas reacciones
yo creo que surfear la ola yo creo que
es una elección que en el caso de que el
resultado final sea el que las encuestas
predicen que yo creo que se van a cerrar
bastante más las encuestas de aquí a
noviembre es una elección que pierde no
dan donald trump que no gana yo byd en
esa la primera la segunda es
mira qué tanto domina la conversación
que en ninguno de los casos de las
intervenciones que hemos tenido
anteriormente hemos hablado de joe biden
en ningún momento hablamos de yo bailé
en el momento en el que nos fuerzas a
contestar sobre algo porque la verdad
más allá de un debate y más allá de un
tuit en el que quiere desea que el
presidente se recupere no hay digamos
algo que tú pudieras decir bueno es una
campaña excepcional y hay una cosa en la
que si difiero
este tramo
si genera empatía da en serio yo sé que
este uno puede pensar que no yo vivo
aquí a veces me sorprendo de todo un
poco español viviendo en eeuu y bueno
somos alegres pero hay cierto folklore
digamos que incluso a mí me supera el
que yo veo las calles porque ves con los
aviones oiga aviones deseando de saludo
al presidente y que pasan por encima de
las casas y uno pensará que eso no
existe y eso es una realidad cuando de
estos tipos vestidos todo con la bandera
americana al gorra mexicano a los
zapatos americana esto es diario por lo
menos en la florida y viran es que ese
estado republicano probablemente sea
porque es un estado republicano pero
tiene una empatía muy alta entre sus
seguidores lo que tiene trump que no
tiene vaivén es que piden perdón trump
si es odiado hay un sector de la
población que odia a donald trump lo
odia es decir este que si lo hubieran
muerto se darían por bien pagados y
bueno insisto en la sopa no una sopa
tiene mucho picante en la otra no tiene
sal entonces este yo creo que dicho el
lenguaje español ni calvo ni con tres
pelucas estamos presenciando una campaña
peores candidatos que han tenido ambos
partidos de la historia de la democracia
me quedo con el plato de la sopa sin san
xavier
víctor su opinión al respecto
yo estoy acuerdo con chávez lo que está
diciendo ahora es verdad son las
debilidad debilidades de trump las que
están haciendo que yo vaivén parezca tan
fuerte pero vaivén no es obama no
despierta pasiones es su incapacidad
para entusiasmar a la mulita a la
multitud debilita sus posibilidades de
éxito frente a 80 los 87 millones de
fieles
seguidores de trump en twitter unido a
ese voto oculto que ya le otorgó la
victoria en 2016 efectivamente trampas
en muchos lectores empaticen con tramos
trans y levanta pasiones a la campaña de
vaivén en estos momentos yo creo que
necesita realizar cambios urgentes que
inspiren y atraigan a los jóvenes a la
población negra a los hispanos al voto
femenino porque es ahí donde reside la
mayor el mayor porcentaje de electores
de alguna manera se tiene que definir a
bailén como alguien decente durable
honesto optimista como un gran líder
capaz de afrontar la grave crisis que
azota al país en un momento tan difícil
pero de alguna manera también vemos a un
yo vaivén con 77 años 78 años perdón que
ya no es tan ágil como debería ser en
momentos de crisis y eso le podría pasar
factura y si el equipo de tren lo logra
posicionar ese relato en los
estadounidenses también pues puede
hacerle daño nuestras últimas etapas de
la elección en las próximas semanas
definitivamente el foco va a estar como
decía enfocado entrar y de todos modos
también en un tema importante que es que
hay dudas sobre si la estrategia de
movilizar a las bases más duras de trans
va a ser la suficiente para darle la
victoria electoral de todos modos yo
creo que lo que más podría ayudar a
trump es que los contagios desciendan
sensiblemente y la economía inicie una
rápida recuperación eso va a ser clave
en estas últimas semanas la economía es
un tema clave
víctor pero justamente hoy
dijo que no iba a seguir negociando con
los demócratas ese paquete de estímulo
para hacer frente a los problemas
económicos que ha dejado la pandemia del
cómic 19 entonces como vemos ese
escenario hay también teniendo en cuenta
traigo aquí sobre la mesa las encuestas
porque las últimas semanas en los
últimos días se han movido mucho incluso
le dan a byd en algunos repuntes en
algunos estados claves estados que
ustedes han mencionado florida que es
este estado que prácticamente define
muchos puntos importantes de la elección
me toca mi verdad mira respecto a los
estados principales los estados en
dólares de los que hablamos sinceramente
ahora mismo deben estar trabajando el
equipo de trauma en torno a los 11
estados principales trump y su equipo
van a intentar mantener los estados
logrados en 2016 como hemos hablado el
sistema electoral del país hace que el
ganador de un estado se lleve todos los
votos de los delegados por lo que ganar
en esos estados de indecisos es
fundamental para llegar a la casa blanca
efectivamente podemos insistir en que
las encuestas favorecen a bailén pero ya
lo hacían en 2016 es muy relativo
y como hemos hablado tantas veces trump
es capaz de todo sea sinceramente yo
creo que las opciones de reelección de
trans siguen siendo reales que le pasó
atrás básicamente o sea primero mal
manejo de la pandemia eeuu la nación más
golpeada por tuve 19 a nivel global con
más de 211 mil fallecidos es el 7.5
millones de contagios y sólo el 30 30 40
por ciento de los estadounidenses lo
aprueba de ahí la economía en enero como
sabéis estaba muy muy bien perdón
y de ahí las manifestaciones las calles
pero sinceramente creo que queda mucho
por recorrer para trampas sabías
rápidamente ya estamos llegando al
último bloque del programa que cartas
pueden jugarse los candidatos en estas
tres semanas que queda
bueno yo creo que la carta de donald
trump es muy clara es la de la
polarización él va a seguir golpeando el
ahora tiene un nuevo enemigo uno que ya
venció que él cobit y el otro son los
demócratas y hoy lo acaba de hacer con
nancy pelosi o sea ya los está poniendo
como los malos como los que no se llegan
acuerdo como los desastrosos en materia
económica ya joe biden sólo le queda una
carta decir que todo esto era un show
que al final es mentira que un tramposo
no puede seguir en la casa blanca que es
una persona mentirosa ahora bien insisto
en un tema que pasa un poco
desapercibido aquí aquí la elección se
va a volver a jugar en lo que le llaman
los partos states que no ni los o los
purpurados o los violetas que son ohio
florida colorado michigan virginia en
minnesota que son estados en los que las
encuestas no se corresponden a las
grandes diferencias es decir amplía la
diferencia este vaivén
nueva york en amplía la diferencia en
california
pero si uno se mira por ejemplo el voto
latino que tenía yo vaivén en la florida
hace cuatro años baile pero don don al
sol de la florida de cuatro años que
estaban en 16 por ciento y en este
momento está en el 29 yo creo que la
noche electoral va a ser de infarto y va
a haber más de una sorpresa porque
evidentemente donde se estamos viendo
donald trump es en los sectores que
precisamente hace cuatro años no le fue
bien yo insisto en una idea para tratar
de rebajar un poco el ambiente con esto
porque al final todos nos ponemos tensos
control de compay de este vaivenes del
esposo perfecto
pero son sigue siendo para muchos
americanos el amante el gandaya el golf
o el sinvergüenza el simpático el
fiestero y acciona no hay que olvidar
que los amantes nunca explican lo que
hacen y al final acaban votando el día
de la elección en silencio y yo creo que
ahí va a haber algún que otro susto
definitivamente concuerdo con usted con
que la elección la noche de la elección
va a estar reñida y va a ser
absolutamente infarto y va a tener al
mundo entero al borde de un ataque de
nervios' con cada voto que den a conocer
de cada uno de los estados maría tereza
para el cierre del programa la
conclusión como guste entonces el
panorama pensando un poco más a futuro
también si trump llega a reelegirse y
permanece en la casa blanca- cuatro años
más en términos internacionales que
representa eso
dicen en eeuu que los grandes cambios
internacionales se hacen en los últimos
cuatro años de un presidente no en los
primeros cuatro porque ya no pierde nada
si le va mal en una guerra ya no pierde
nada si pierde una guerra y tenemos un
mundo bastante convulsionado nagorno
karabaj que tenemos un enemigo que lo ha
dicho trump durante cuatro años que es
irán una elección de trump después de
ese voto en el que el que gane
seguramente van a ganar por una nariz
como dicen los que apuestan a los
caballos va a ser un mundo convulsionado
donde el tema de irán puede volverse
realmente explosivo pero yo esperaría a
ver qué pasa el 3 de noviembre antes de
afirmar todo eso
pues les agradezco a los tres invitados
por haber estado con nosotros por
habernos puesto en perspectiva esta
situación esta coyuntura electoral en
eeuu debido a la enfermedad al
diagnóstico de kobe 19 del presidente de
donald trump quien aspira a la
reelección y quien disputa esta elección
con joe biden del partido demócrata
ustedes pueden seguir dejando a todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales gracias por su
sintonía siga con la programación de
france 24
[Música]